what we're doing is that we're building
everything and designing everything with
the greater vision in mind
right so everything we're doing today
becomes a piece of the puzzle of the
greater
um
futuristic vision
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctek
hello everyone and welcome to 20 minute
leaders today we're talking with the ceo
of a fascinating company store ai meet
mendel ginowicz
mendel is the ceo of store ai a leading
provider of end-to-end digitization
solutions for grocers he moved to israel
in 2018 because of his passion for
israeli innovation with the intention of
helping israeli startups go global a
passion which has directly contributed
to success at story
prior to being appointed ceo he was the
company's executive vice president of
business development spearheading store
ai's 300 percent year-on-year growth in
the midst of the covet-19 pandemic
previously he was vice president of
business development and vice president
of retail development at impacts media a
digital communications company for
grocers where he was responsible for the
company's strategic positioning in the
grocery and advertising industries and
working with retailers and engineers to
tailor products to the company's network
throughout mr ginowicz career he has
been in the forefront of building new
organizations from the ground up both a
strategic developer and a marketer
challenging the status quo to make
positive impact on people's lives he is
also actively engaged in pro bono work
to help other israeli companies expand
outside the country
you know the work that you're doing with
stored ai is fascinating on many fronts
particularly
this question of the intersection of
technology with with the physical world
with the retail food with grocers
understanding you know fulfillment
supply chains consumer behavior the way
that these businesses are operating but
then
this whole sphere having to do with
technology and so that is exactly you
know my the the
my personal interest and i'm excited to
pick your brain a little bit about your
own you know the journey of stuart rei
your own journey then a little bit about
your writing sites as to the vertical in
the world so thank you very very much
for joining me mendel tell me just a
little bit about yourself you know the
transition
today you're the ceo of stuart ai
what has your
personal journey been like leading up to
store.ai
so personally um i was born to parents
who are kobatnikim
but also entrepreneurs
and my dad
i was always taking us from one country
to the next from one city to the next
following his dreams
um he was one of the first people in
that to sell anything online he was
selling jewelry online
uh in the 90s and uh early 2000s
and uh built up a pretty good name for
himself he stole the business that
called ice.com in 2007.
and uh so i grew up in an
entrepreneurial family
and so you know i always had a passion
for for entrepreneurialism for business
and um
when i married an israeli woman and
brought her to canada
um
it was pretty easy for her to convince
me to come back to israel
where we could join you know this
amazing startup nation and bring
something
extraordinary to the world and so that
was uh that's basically my journey uh in
terms of how i got here
um
the uh the journey within story eyes
that i started about five years ago as
uh vp business deaf
and my role was to do partnerships with
other companies that would you know
extend and expand our product and our
offering
and uh give us the really interesting uh
solution for grocers
and uh i was recently promoted to ceo
when the last ceo left the company
and uh it's you know obviously humbling
for me to be offered this position
uh but also a huge opportunity because
of the amazing theme that i have
i was able to say yes
um knowing that we're going to be wildly
successful so that's really my kind of
story into this
well so so no just picking up on that
you know you're joining a startup it's
it's a fast-growing startup still
start-up how many people were you when
he joined
uh we were 16 people when i joined
wow
we're about 70 now
incredible so 16 people
you know there's already a dynamic in
place where you're joining you know
there's a
there's there's a vision there's a
mission there's some history and all of
a sudden you find yours and and you're
looking at the ceo and the decisions
that they're made and i'm guessing that
there is some distance between you know
your position as vp and the decisions
that are being made and all of a sudden
here a few years later
you're now the one running the ship
right and you're running the narrative
and you're picking up on and you have to
basically adopt
also that whole experience uh from the
beginning and owned that story
what is that like owning that story of a
startup
as if from inception because now you are
running the ship of store ai
and
and and i'm sure it's just a fascinating
transition
absolutely i i think one of the reasons
that i was elected to be ceo is because
throughout my time
previous to my
beginning studio before i was single uh
i was always involved in the in the
vision in the mission in setting the
strategy in you know understanding the
needs of the greater market obviously
we're a very strong player here in
israel but really our bigger market
opportunities of course outside of
israel and so i was always in touch with
the um
you know the foreign world the world of
the us and the uk market and so that was
probably a big part of why i became ceo
and so
the transition in terms of strategically
leading the company is actually not very
big the bigger transition is now being
responsible um for the well-being of the
team for the collaboration for the uh
the execution and the focus of the team
and that's really where the bigger
transition happened for me
and all of those things are you know
absolutely critical so when you look at
how to be a successful ceo of a tech
startup or of any company really
it's all about your your people it
starts with the people
then it moves on to the focus you know
making sure everyone's doing
the focusing on the right thing
and then making sure that once they're
focusing on the right thing they're
executing so those are actually our
three pillars
um of our company uh that that we
preached and that we try to live and
breathe at all times it's team
focus and execution
incredible okay so
tell me a little bit about grocers the
physical and digital world
in 2022 wha what what's happening even
before story i
where are we at today what's sort of the
big problem
so
if you if you really understand grocery
and i think that one of the things that
you know
grocery tech startups
have to understand if they want to be
successful is that grocery
is an extremely complex business that
has been building layers and layers of
complexity over the last hundred years
you know in
the first traditional grocery store was
established was called piggly wiggly in
the u.s and that's where you walk
throughout the aisles and ever since
then there have been layers and layers
of complexity that have been built up
ran
uh positioning of products
um you know
advertising within stores
uh inventory management it is an
absolute beast of a business
industry
and so
what is so difficult about penetrating
this industry is actually finding
solutions for the very very very many
layers of complexity that exist within
the grocery world
i think once you understand the actual
grocery world which is what we do so
well especially because we've hired
executives from the grocery world
once you understand that that it is such
a complex beast and that you can
bring value to specific areas of that
complexity from technology then you
really have the opportunity to make a
big impact so if we take you know if we
can get a little bit more specific
let's say we want to sell groceries
online which is you know our core
product right so
um
companies like traditional e-commerce
platforms like salesforce for example
they're trying to get into the grocery
space but they're struggling and the
major reason they're struggling is
because of how complex it is so i'll
give you a simple example uh if you're
if you have a barcode which would
typically be let's say your uh upc or if
you're if you're in a warehouse you'd
scan a barcode and it would connect to
your inventory management et cetera et
cetera in grocery if you have a barcode
for a weightable product like a
pack of meat right or something like
that
half the barcode is the meat and half is
like uh the weight and so
basically you're dealing with a layer of
complexity that works in store but if
you don't have that
knowledge of the ins and outs and the
little tiny details of groceries you'll
never be successful
and so that's something that we do
really well on many many different
levels
is understanding the real pains of the
grocer and then being able to bring
technological solutions to those needs
right and so if we're looking at
the transition with the solution that
that story i provide to the to the exact
problem that you mentioned that extra
layer of complexity how are you
leveraging technology to to make it
simpler
well really what we're doing is let's
say for example um
understanding that retailers or many
retailers
work with uh inventory management on a
per store basis right okay each store
will have their own inventory uh that
obviously works back it works its way
back up to the general inventory
management system
many retailers are using their pos
system um like their checkout till
system to actually manage that inventory
many retailers are using traditional
inventory management system but when we
understand that and then we integrate
and sync with those inventory management
systems on a first store or for
uh warehouse level
we could then bring a technological
solution which is that integration
actually be in sync with what's going on
online
so i think about it if you if you came
to a grocer with a typical ecommerce
platform right like a shopify or magento
or salesforce uh they're typically used
to invent connecting to one inventory
management system
pulling the data and publishing it
online right we have to connect to many
many different inventory management
systems and then publish them each their
own store level that's one let that one
way where the complexity of grocery is
something that's not typical and when
you have a technological solution that
you've built over years
to address that issue you could really
have uh you know what we could call in
our industry you can have a
technological moat or you can have
something that really makes you
different uh than any competitors trying
to get into the space
right now now for looking at
the complexity of
of running you know this type of
operation and it sounds like there's a
lot of
there's a lot of logistics behind there
so there's a lot of operations there's a
lot of syncing and integration which is
exactly where story is coming to place
if we were to rethink
in european the way that we're we're
looking at grocers today the physical
and retail the physical and digital
world
is this the right solution i mean and
what i'm what i'm considering right now
is this question of if we're looking
worldwide at the way that we're actually
you know
the way that our digital world works in
the physical world
is this the right way to run and i'm
trying to think you know 20 30 years
into the future
of how do we continue integrating
between the physical and digital world
so our vision at store ai for
the long term vision of this industry
is very different than what it is today
right so
the way we see this industry going is a
combination of digital and physical
uh and e-commerce and in-store
but where the in-store shopping
becomes more like a shook a market
experience right where when you walk
into the store you're only buying fresh
goods and you're only buying things that
are appealing to your senses
for your taste you know you you see a
vendor selling pizza in a in a beautiful
pizza oven you have a fish monger
smelling fish and a professional butcher
and that's really when we look at where
millennials are going is they're going
back
with these things they want to go to the
butcher they want to go to the fish
market they want to touch the fish and
things like that
but on the other hand
nobody cares to touch the boxes stereo
or the roll of toilet paper before they
bring it home right
right
all
the let's say mundane things or the dry
goods that you actually buy week to week
you don't really care about and even
things that are like
a little bit more specialized like maybe
a cheese or something you know some of
those things if you already know what
you want all of that is going to be done
online and the fulfillment of that will
either be done uh through a delivery or
pick up in store but all of it will be
robotic uh you know robotic fulfillment
there'll be no picking and there will be
no people walking around stores
what's going to happen is when you go to
a grocery store in the future it's all
going to be about this experience right
so you walk into the store and you'll
have maybe a stroke of different market
vendors uh of us fishmonger of a butcher
and whatnot you'll go and you have the
senses you'll have the taste and the
smells and then you'll you'll buy
whatever you want in the store maybe a
new kind of beer or a new kind of cheese
and then your basics will be either
delivered to you in store or sent to
your house
all with a layer of digitization and
personalization that's above it all so
even when you're in store right you'll
open up your application and you'll see
hey there's a new kind of cheese and we
know that you love cheeses why don't you
try it or
your your favorite craft beer company
has released a new flavor go give it a
try so all these things will be uh in
sync and then when you go back to your
online those same things that you've
experienced in store will then be pushed
to you online so that you have a really
wonderful cross-channel
experience as a consumer
wow and so
as the ceo running this ship you're
balancing you know you're balancing 2022
in today's world
with the needs of these different stores
and and their needs are obviously based
on the current experiences and the
current vision of what some may have of
what's happening today because obviously
not everybody's going to to have this
grand vision of how how the world is
going to look so how do you balance as a
company
and you want to strategically position
yourself as a market later in that
greater vision that's you know where the
holy grail is how do you position
yourself
with that you're both running today's
com today's story ai but you're also
navigating and and creating an
opportunity
so that story i can continue to lead
also in this next phase
yeah it's a good question um
what we're doing is that we're building
everything and designing everything with
the greater vision in mind
right so everything we're doing today
becomes a piece of the puzzle of the
greater
um
futuristic vision so for example when we
have our picking application which is
the best picking application for order
fulfillment in the world
right when we build that
what we're doing is we're saying okay
this is an application that
in the future can
support uh all sorts of in-store
digitization right
and then when we build our e-commerce
we're saying well
what do we get what do we need to do to
support future e-commerce needs or
things like that so for example one of
the things that we
have in our road map is
excuse me is pre-ordering uh products
before you go into the physical store so
imagine right imagine we have this great
store that we talked about it's only
like a marketplace and it's only the
products that you really love but before
you go into the store you know that
there's always a big line at the cheese
counter right and you know that you want
to do specific things so in your
application
you just click on the cheeses that you
want and you walk in and you pick them
up and they're ready for you right so
building towards that and thinking about
partnerships with uh the right uh
robotic fulfillment companies and and uh
you know all the different things that
go into
the next level of the digital uh
retailer we're building all those things
uh side by side with our layer of data
and personalization that
that is surrounding it all
and you know as we continue to build we
get closer and closer to our vision
whereas you know in the very near future
we'll have all the pieces of the puzzle
to have that visit in place and we can
even start selling it to the retailer as
a you know futuristic store that he can
he or she can you know start bringing
even in the next five years
well
you know and i'm and obviously
the
the it's not a black or white thing
right i mean because right now we're
talking about you know the in-store
experience the physical experience and
then we're talking about the digital
world and
it's not
not a moonshot thought
the idea that yes we do we may want to
experience the stores a certain way just
because i go to the store to experience
the cheese doesn't have to walk out with
that cheese right i mean logistically uh
there's a difference between the
experience versus what happens to when i
get home and potentially with you know
if you if you manage to to solve that
supply chain you're able to get home and
the cheese is already waiting for you
and and they got there before you you
left the store right which uh and and
that's that obviously opens new windows
of opportunity
now from a leadership perspective
you're now the ceo of story i and i'm
going back to this because this is such
a special situation that is so uncommon
and it's so fascinating for me you know
if you're looking internally at this
transition
was that was trivial
was it you know did everybody everybody
just you know got on board did you have
to make any changes what how did you
approach
this idea of you becoming the ceo
yeah so it's not trivial at all
actually i'm quite a young guy i'm only
30 years old so
many of my peers and the people
reporting to me are a lot older than me
right and so
it was definitely not trivial and i had
to gain their trust
the good news was that i was already had
a personal relationship with all of this
executives
we are all you know we have that level
of friendship but then i had to prove
myself as a leader in this space
and uh i did do a few you know
calculated moves in order to do that
uh firstly
by
creating our three pillars right so
creating a an infrastructure for success
um implementing additional uh let's say
okrs is one thing right
taking best practices from the best
companies in the world and implementing
them here at story i to make sure that
we are the gold standard of a place to
work now obviously
it doesn't happen overnight rome wasn't
built in a day right but we're already
at a point today
where
i am
i think
you know humbly that that i've been
accepted as the leader
and we're able to make that you know
that move forward together as a team
rather than you know the ambiguity of
what's going on so it did take some time
and it wasn't secure right away and you
know the first reaction that i got from
some of the executives was uh well we
don't know if we're gonna stay you know
we were in love with the last ceo and i
was also and i said you know that's a
perfectly
uh you know it's a perfectly acceptable
statement right i understand you and why
you would maybe not want to stay but
let's give it a start for a few months
and see how things go
and um
i tried to lead
uh with compassion and lead will allow
people
to be their best selves my leadership
style is very much
to uh give people the responsibility and
the accountability
so we make them responsible for their
things and then accountable at the end
when you end up doing that and when you
have such talented and experienced
people
you get to really uh you know
rely on them to do what they're doing
and they come back with results so you
know
very much not a micro manager i'm very
much a big vision kind of big picture
kind of person and when i do that
and they've learned over the last few
months that they can trust me to give
them the responsibility and then expect
the accountability of the results
they've realized that you know i i can
be somebody who they can continue to
develop their career with and build
an enormous company with
mandel thank you so much this was so
enjoyable and fascinating and best of
luck with story i love the fact that
your vision you know it takes whatever
you have today but you're thinking
through consumer behavior and you're
thinking about the changing world and
you're presenting a greater vision for
what could be and what story i could
position itself to be a leader at so
thank you very very much thank you best
of luck and stay safe and say hello bye
[Music]